bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 Soy Luis Muñoz el 20 de marzo
de 2003 hace exactamente 20 años Fue la
fecha en la que comenzó la guerra de
Irak una invasión multinacional liderada
por Estados Unidos que tenía el objetivo
de derrocar al régimen de Sadam husein
con la justificación de evitar el uso y
desarrollo de armas de destrucción
masiva un casus belli que dos décadas
después se ha demostrado que fue falso
ya que Irak nunca tuvo esas armas pero
que ha provocado decenas de miles de
muertos y asumido a Irak en una espiral
de violencia e inestabilidad que todavía
sufre hasta el día de hoy
para 2003 la relación entre Estados
Unidos e Irak ya no era buena Sadam
hussein fue Aliado de Washington durante
la década de 1980 pero tras invadir
Kuwait en 1990 Estados Unidos intervino
contra Bagdad y expulsó a las tropas de
aquí es en la conocida como Guerra del
Golfo en los años siguientes la escalada
de tensión fue creciendo Y esto comenzó
a ser especialmente visible tras los
atentados del 11 de septiembre de 2001
en Nueva York el entonces presidente
George W Bush inició su conocida guerra
contra el terror e incluyó a Irak junto
con Irán y Corea del Norte en su famoso
eje del mal Estados Unidos sostenía que
Irak tenía armas de destrucción masiva y
se mostró decidido a intervenir con el
apoyo de Naciones Unidas tal y como
había pasado en 2001 con Afganistán sin
embargo este apoyo nunca llegó numerosas
naciones no vieron consistencia en sus
pruebas y defendieron operación violaba
el derecho internacional algo que no
frenó a Bush que junto al ex Primer
Ministro británico Tony Blair y al
expresidente del gobierno español José
María aznar lanzó un última tuma a Don
hussein desde las Islas azores
la respuesta de hussein nunca llegó y la
coalición internacional inició los
ataques el 20 de marzo las imágenes de
Bagdad siendo bombardeada esa noche por
misiles estadounidenses dieron la vuelta
al mundo la coalición internacional
quería neutralizar lo antes posible a
las tropas iraquíes para terminar cuanto
antes la guerra
Seguiremos en nuestra tarea hasta que
hayamos alcanzado Nuestro objetivo que
es liberar a Irak de las armas de
destrucción masiva y liberar al pueblo
iraquí para que pueda vivir en una
sociedad esperanzada y democrática en
paz en su vecindad tras varias semanas
de combate tropas estadounidenses
entraron el 7 de abril de 2003 en Bagdad
sin encontrar mucha resistencia esos
días se vivieron momentos históricos en
la capital iraquí tras casi 24 años en
el poder la dictadura de Sadam husein
cayó a imágenes como el derrumbe de su
estatua en Bagdad pasaron a la historia
Estados Unidos creó la autoridad
provisional de la coalición Un gobierno
dirigido por la coalición internacional
y terminó su invasión en el resto del
territorio el 1 de Mayo de 2003
las principales operaciones de combate
en Irak han concluido en la batalla de
Irak Estados Unidos y nuestros aliados
han prevalecido
[Aplausos]
la liberación de Irak es un avance
crucial en la campaña contra el terror
hemos eliminado a un Aliado de al qaeda
y cortado una fuente de financiación
terrorista
sin embargo la toma de Irak no trajo la
detención de Sadam husein quien pudo
huir a tiempo durante meses se priorizó
su búsqueda Hasta que el 14 de diciembre
de 2003 Sadam fue localizado en un zulo
en su ciudad natal tigrid el Antiguo
dictador fue detenido y enjuiciado
Durante los siguientes años por crímenes
de lesa humanidad por usar armas
químicas durante la década de los 80 su
destino fue la horca siendo ejecutado un
30 de diciembre de 2006
pero la caída de hussein no trajo
estabilidad ni prosperidad para Irak las
armas de destrucción masiva que habían
justificado la invasión nunca
aparecieron además aunque Irak vivió un
proceso democratizador y pudo celebrar
sus primeras elecciones en el año 2005
los atentados terroristas se
multiplicaron Y aunque los aliados
occidentales tenían el control de las
principales ciudades la lucha contra
grupos Insurgentes convirtió a esta
guerra en un conflicto de desgaste
esta situación se sumaron los escándalos
protagonizados por las tropas
extranjeras que cada vez contaban con
menos apoyo de la población soldados
estadounidenses realizaron torturas y
vejaciones a prisioneros iraquíes en
varias cárceles las imágenes en las que
se mostraba a varios militares mofándose
y humillando a prisioneros
escandalizaron a la opinión
internacional la guerra en Irak empezó a
tener cada vez menos sentido y con la
llegada al poder de Barack Obama La
retirada de tropas comenzó a hacerse
efectiva hasta que concluyó en 2011
Estados Unidos salió de Irak sin haber
logrado el objetivo de estabilizar a la
joven democracia iraquí y eso como era
previsible tuvo consecuencias en el
corto plazo Irak se convirtió en un
estado fallido que sufrió el flagelo del
estado islámico a quien cedió un tercio
de su territorio en 2014 otra coalición
internacional tuvo que llegar al país
para combatir a este grupo yihadista
logrando derrotarlos en 2017 y restaurar
la normalidad en el norte del país tras
años de poder insurgente 20 años después
se sabe que los pretextos para iniciar
la guerra las armas de destrucción
masiva y los supuestos vínculos de San
José y con al qaeda son falsos pero las
consecuencias de esta se siguen pagando
en Irak la cantidad de fallecidos
totales como consecuencia del conflicto
varía en función de la Fuente Aunque la
mayoría de los casos se sitúa por encima
de los 200.000 Muertos hoy los iraquíes
sufren a diario tres males cada vez más
difíciles de combatir pobreza una crisis
económica sistémica y violencia con esto
concluimos Gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de France
24.com
[Música]